Diving is an activity to carry out in pairs.
It is critical that buddies support each other...
...starting at the preparatory phase for a well-planned dive.
When you are getting ready for a dive, make sure you proceed...
...at the same pace of your buddies...
...so that you are all ready at the same time.
In this way, you will not have to wait for the others...
...with your suit on and overheat.
If you do overheat, cool down and never accumulate excessive heat.
Once the gear is on, do the buddy check and then enter the water,...
...ready for the real adventure.
Remember that as soon as you are on the surface,...
...you should exchange the snorkel with the regulator...
...so that you can save air in the tank.
Swim on the surface until you get to the descent point...
...the instructor will indicate.
Exchange the snorkel with the regulator...
...and start the descent with your buddy.
Remember to equalize your ears as soon as you start the descent...
...and give the OK signal to your buddy.